-Welcome back to "Late Night."
We are here with Ana Gasteyer.
We were talking
about the holidays.
You have a daughter in college.
You have a son in eighth grade.
And I heard you gave
your eighth-grader
a very beloved gift.
-Well, so, I was locked in
the room because I had COVID.
And so my plan was,
as it often is --
'cause it was a panicky year.
I had a very busy fall.
So my plan is, usually,
to land in Albuquerque,
where my folks live, and then
I hit Target, hit Costco,
you know, do a bunch
of last-minute shopping.
But because I got sick,
I was screwed.
I had like four gifts
total planned,
and most of them
were not here in New York.
So I panicked.
I turned to the hive-mind
of the "SNL" ladies.
Our friend Paula Pell naturally
came up with a gift --
best gift of all time,
which is a remote-controlled
fart machine.
And I really can't
recommend this more.
It's a crowd-pleaser not just
for my 13-year-old son,
but for people everywhere --
for people and friends.
And I got Amazon's choice,
so I got the highest quality one
that I could.
You know, I went for the --
I did my research.
You know, I'm not gonna be
leaving a nasty review there.
And I gotta tell you something.
This gift was such
a four-star -- five-star --
five-star -- four out of four,
five out of five, winner.
So if you are looking for,
you know,
a last-minute Valentine's gift
or whatever for your wife,
it is something that
can really fill in in a pinch.
And we've been using it
around the home.
It just comes up.
It comes up all the time.
It's very useful.
-And does it play into the video
that you brought for us?
-Oh, yeah, this is the ways
in which it can be used
to humiliate your friends
and relatives.
I mean, that's the function of a
remote-controlled fart machine,
'cause you can plant it,
walk away, and then --
It's a very spot-on and very --
The library of fart sounds
I find very well-curated.
It is not your garden-variety
fart machine.
They've really gone
the extra mile.
But I did hear some chuckles.
It's a self-amusement toy.
I walked through because
we had the ice skating on --
because we've gotta know
what's coming up
for the United States Olympics.
-Right.
-Olympic team.
And so I walked through
my living room the other day
to find an incredibly
self-satisfied 13-year-old,
and that's what the video is.
-The next thought I had -- I was
just jotting down this note --
is I --
[ Farting ]
...program this music on him
so much.
It matches his personality.
Very debonair.
♪♪
[ Fart ]
[ Farting ]
-You know, I really tip my cap.
A very judicious use of it.
Didn't overdo it.
Perfectly landed each one.
-Yeah, well, you've gotta
really take your time with it.
Exactly. And you never know
what's coming down the pipe.
Thank you, thank you.
I'll let him know
that you approved.
That was Ulysses McKitrick's
craftsmanship.
I think we've got a future
as a sound editor.
-Yes, let's make sure
he gets his credit,
because the credit is due.
So, we overlapped for a year
at "SNL," Ana.
And then we got to work together
one more time
on the very famous
Betty White episode.
Betty sadly passed,
but it was so nice
to be able to share with people
how special that week was.
And you were a part of,
you know, for my money,
some of the best moments
of that episode.
What do you remember
from that week?
-That was a magical week.
I know we've talked
about it before.
I actually was so touched
that NBC re-aired it.
I thought it was such
a great way to honor her,
because I always say
show business is the
fountain of youth,
that people who live in our
world have this kind of --
You have to be so elastic,
and you have to
keep up with the times.
And she was such, as you know,
a perfect, perfect
living example of that.
She hosted when she was 88,
and she may as well have been --
whatever -- 25.
I mean, she was so up
on every joke, every nuance.
And looking back on the show --
I hadn't watched it
since we did it 11 years ago
until last Saturday.
Everything's just so --
You know, there's some racy
stuff in there, and she was --
she understood
every single joke.
She knew how to set it up,
how to walk away.
You know what I mean?
-Yeah.
-Yeah, so, for me, that week,
it definitely was
the beginning of --
Not to be all artsy-fartsy
or, you know, whatever,
psych about it.
It was a really cool week
because it brought together
a lot of women from sort of
two generations of "SNL"
and it helped kind of
solidify this idea
of a female presence
on the show, I think.
It was by accident
because it was Mother's Day
and we were really there
for her.
But I think our shared adulation
of her and the community
and writing together with other
women, it was pretty incredible.
It set in motion
a real sorority, as you know,
that exists amongst us, so...
-Well, it's great because,
you know,
not just films
like "Wine Country"
that happened after the fact
that, you know,
collects everybody
who came back for that show,
but also --
You know,
we've talked about it before,
and I've talked about it
with pretty much everybody
on said text chain,
but you guys are on the hottest
text chain in the biz,
which is these
"SNL" female, you know, alumni.
And I'm deeply jealous
not to be a part of it,
but I'm just happier
knowing that it exists.
-It definitely exists.
It's a huge part
of all of our lives.
And again, like I've said,
we've talked about it,
this sorority of girlfriends.
I mean, mostly, at this point,
it's just, you know,
recipes and, you know,
Christmas gift ideas
such as remote-control
fart machines.
But, you know,
a fountain of [Laughs]
a fountain of useful
information, to be honest.
But, yeah, I think
the Betty part of it
is that she really was
the cornerstone,
which is really incredible
when I think about what was
set in motion, you know?
-Yeah, it's really amazing
that, again,
I mean, not just that she could
have that incredible episode.
And then for the last 10 years
after that episode,
she did so many other
deeply funny things.
But she did
bring people together,
mostly because there was
such a core sweetness to her
and really reminded everybody
who was there that week,
"Oh, we should count ourselves
as deeply lucky
that we get to do this
for a living."
-Absolutely.
Super optimistic.
Came from a really
optimistic standpoint.
Looked for the joke.
Looked for --
I mean, you know, I remember
everyone was running around
all nervous that she
was gonna be overtired
'cause she was doing "MacGruber"
till 3:00 in the morning
or whatever, you know?
-Yeah.
-And I remember, like,
saying to her --
it might have been Saturday
morning, Friday morning --
"How are you doing?
You worked really late."
She was like,
"Oh, I went back to my room.
It was fine. I had a vodka
and a hot dog, and I slept."
You know, it's sort of like
how you want to live
at 88, you know?
Have an vodka -- an vodka --
and an hot dog and go to bed,
you know, and then wake up and
go do an incredible comedy show
with a huge number of amazing
and, you know,
relevant young people.
Super, super inspiring.
-Well, it was a special week
to be a part of,
and it's always great
to see you.
Thanks so much
for being here, Ana.
-Hey, thanks for having me.
Enjoy "American Auto."
I'm really proud of it.
-Ana Gasteyer, everybody.
"American Auto" airs
Tuesday nights here on NBC
and streams any time on Peacock.